when I first met God many years ago I
would always hear people say this is the
day that the Lord has made I will
rejoice and be glad in it we could say
that about this year couldn't we we
could say that about this is the year
that God has made you know it kind of
represents almost a stewardship issue
that I've got this year in front of me
and I have the opportunity to manage
this year for God and His glory for my
family for my future I have the ability
to be intentional about it to be a
victor and not a victim about it I get
to decide also like the old praise song
they used to sing a hundred years ago
when you know I was 30-some years ago it
feels like his mercies it's from
Scripture his mercies are new every
morning and you know this time of year
we stop and think about stuff like that
this is the time of year when you stop
and say I get a clean slate his mercies
are new every year I get a new year the
new years in front of me it's clean it's
optional
what I make of it but here's the thing a
large number of people walk through life
as if in a dream as if they were somehow
controlled by someone else as if they
had no impact on their own destiny yes
there's outside variables there's not
saying that's not things that happen to
us that we can't control you could drive
through a stoplight today and some more
someone could drive to the stoplight
natrium today you've got no way of
fixing that you can't control that y'all
you can controls how you react to all of
the things that are going to happen this
year and you can control whether or not
you're going to choose to be a force of
nature in your own life a sense of
intentionality a sense of yeah there's
things out there that happen and there's
things that I can't control but there's
a whole bunch of things I maybe just
need to take some first steps on getting
some control
in areas of my life you hate your job
you need to be listening to the Ken
Coleman show on Sirius XM 132 but if you
hate your job maybe you need to do
something about it I've never really
understood people who spend year after
year after year doing something they
hate that indicates that you don't think
you have any power yeah you do begin to
take this different you don't walk out
today and quit and leave your family
with no ability to buy groceries I'm not
suggesting that but for goodness sakes
if you've been in a job for five years
that you hate set yourself up to say by
the end of the year I'm not gonna be
doing this anymore
I'm gonna do something what am I gonna
do what steps have I got to take what
classes have I gotta take what
certifications have I gonna take how do
I start my own business
what am I gonna do but in the air I'm
stuck in debt no you're not your brain
is stuck but you're not stuck in that
we've walked millions of people out of
that you can't become wealthy in America
today oh yeah you can 10 million plus
millionaires and 90 something percent of
them started with nothing and that's in
America today you're not stuck and the
man doesn't control you and the politics
of the GOP or the Democrats don't run or
ruin your life you do you do it's the
power of intentionality the power of
saying I'm gonna be intentional about
what I want out of this area of my life
because what you plant in that area of
your life if you plant nothing you're
gonna grow a big old big butt crop of
nothing you plant nothing you're gonna
get nothing back in man you don't get a
bumper crop nothing right back
what if you say hey I'm gonna change my
physical life this year how many of us
are going to lose some weight yeah me
too
I hate my weight in Christmas cookies
it's time to start fresh right yeah god
I got to break this guy's got to start
man got to get on with it you know I'm
gonna get myself in better financial
condition I'm gonna change jobs I'm
gonna impact my marriage I'm going to do
differently with the kiddos
other relationships I've got a good
friend sent me a note yesterday guys you
know everybody's got these great grant
your resolutions I'm just gonna not be
as grouchy I thought for that guy that's
probably a good idea
he was probably aiming that at me too
I'm just gonna not be as grouchy there's
not gonna be as negative you know so he
begin to lay out some things
ask yourself what has to be true that's
not true today for this area of my life
to be completely different by the end of
the year and that's not a resolution
that's a goal and that's admitting and
saying this is the year that God is made
I'm gonna rejoice and be glad in it I'm
gonna impact I'm gonna plant so that I
harvest intentionally I'm not going to
I've got a friend that has been watching
CNN and Fox News 24/7 we're gonna have
to put the boy in a rubber room it is
ruined his life he needs to say I'm
gonna put different things into my brain
this year garbage in garbage out cause I
mean really they spent an awful lot of
time just trying to come up with
something to say yeah we're on both
those stations and we're friends with
most those folks I'm not mad at them or
anything like that but really if you
just sit and watch the news all day long
you're gonna just want to just explode
and I'm telling you find something else
to feed your brain with this year make a
decision to impact and make me and and
cause things to happen in your life if
you hate your job by the end the year
leaf do not stay in a job you hate not
more than 12 months and if you don't
take steps to begin to get out of there
you're not ever gonna get out of there
you're not stuck because anybody you're
stuck because you think you're stuck
you're
stuck in debt for any reason other than
you think you're stuck you're not stuck
in middle class or lower class or
poverty in America any more than because
you think you're stuck it's a mentality
so make a decision this is the year that
the Lord is made rejoice
happy new year and be glad in it decided
to do something different this year so
that you get something different this
year this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]